- So Livermorium was first made in around 2000.
It was made in calcium-48 plus curium-248 reaction.
We've since made 4 different isotopes of Livermorium.
They all have tens of milliseconds half-lives, so they're pretty short-lived.
So unfortunately I can't show you a bottle.
It was a very interesting process to name these
elements when we got permission to name
114 and 116-were naming two elements at once.
We of course began discussions with our Russian colleagues and reached a concensus
on these names, Flerovium for 114 and Livermorium for 116.
We chose Livermorium because we
could not discover enough elements
to name one after everybody who was
important in these kinds of experiments.
There was many, many scientists here at Livermore.
Some have retired, even passed away, who
were involved in heavy element research.
So we couldn't discover enough elements
and name after every single person.
So we chose Livermorium to honor all those people,
honor the institution here and the city of Livermore.
We thought this was an appropriate way to kind of
recognize all of those scientists involved in that work.
- You spent some time in the community.
I know you talk with scholars, you know people.
How has that decision been received by the institution and the people of Livermore?
They must...
- It's been outstanding.
The mayor of Livermore is a water chemist,
so he understands chemistry.
He was ecstatic that this came about.
He understood the significance of a new element
and that particular name on the periodic table.
He's been very supportive. We have a Livermorium day now, which is in late May.
They've also named a part of a park, a Plaza in downtown Livermore: Livermorium Plaza.
They've been supportive, very
ecstatic about it, and understand...
I think this community here, because this lab is here, people are a little more scientifically understanding
or scientifically literate, So they understand the significance of it.
So it's been nothing but supportive for that element.
So one of the predicted properties,
because it's in group 16,
It's in the column in the periodic table where
many of the hydrogen compounds of that group
are very smelly. So think about hydrogen sulfide - the rotten eggs smell.
Hydrogen selenide.
- Oh, Selenium...
- Yes. Selenium is notorious for being very smelly.
Rotten garlic or something like that,
It's described at. Telluride. The telluride, tellurium, is also very smelly.
So if you think about going down
that column in the periodic table,
you might say that Livermorium is maybe the smelliest element on the periodic table.
It would be very difficult to verify, because we haven't made the hydrogen compound of it.
The isotopes, as I mentioned, are 10
milliseconds long, so it's very difficult.
And, in addition, you probably wouldn't want to smell it, because it's radioactive
and you wouldn't want to actually put your nose on it and smell it.
Hydrogen sulfide won't hurt you... it'll
hurt in strong-enough concentrations,
but everyone smelled rotten eggs before.
You wouldn't want to do that with Livermorium.
(Audio from "More from Superheavy Videos") So, let's keep going and see where the experiment is
So, as we go along here, the ions are going faster and faster and faster...
...all the time inside the tube
here you see such a target wheel
(...) which is mounted on the axis of this motor here
its ends like this